yes I'm gonna
we read from earlier I was raised in
Bolivia born in California and both my
person from Bolivia and I lived all over
like all over places so Hong Kong I live
in Indonesia for a little bit
Bolivia New Jersey Florida yeah
Boston Bolivia till 12 parents no I grew
up with
my grandma a little bit and my mom
because my mom had me when she was 15 so
my grandma you know helped her she was
still a baby
how was your childhood um my it was um
it was nice but there are some points
are nice but you obviously remember like
the bad things for some reason so my mom
my mom she she wasn't my dad my dad left
me when I was like six to America I did
it okay
and I had my grandma who raised me my
mom she was there too but she faded
these guys all the time they were into
people and so she wasn't around that
much
and she strength a lot so yeah so yeah
these guys sometimes are nice but like I
had there was one who I saw him as a
father figure and he like he I guess he
like he molested me as a man and the
other one used to hit my mom like six or
something yeah yeah when you see my mom
but yeah but I was with my grandma and
she was a good cram from you know like
there are nice parts about my infancy
like we used to go to the out of the
country in Bolivia and like there was
cows and like you know and you go and
like ride horses with my grandpa he's
he's not really my grandpa by he was the
one who was married to my grandma yeah
but my mom's not a bad mom she's not
like that anymore like she she tries to
be a good mom to my three-year-old
brother now yeah so when I was 11 she
graduated from lawyer school and then we
left the country to Florida because we
couldn't get away from this guy like
this guy wouldn't respect nobody like so
yeah we laugh and I started come I was
in America and I was a good girl before
you know like I had I was a good student
and then I know I always many very
rebellious so I guess I just alright at
14 I started playing with my mom like
every teenager and you know starts
fighting my mother and I asked my dad if
I could move in with him so I went to
George he's live with him and it wasn't
a good experience either but it's the
first time I tried drugs was with a
that's brother and like it's weird
because he was watching porn and he
asked me if orange smoke weed you know
like like you don't act like you didn't
see when I was in my car and it was a
pie I never saw it but I smoke weed and
that's the first time I tried anything
and I went to an art school I started
like cutting myself and stuff I didn't
you I didn't even get it from a movie
like it just it was like a natural
instinct to do you know at this date
because I was really depressed with my
dad my dad was really protective like I
live with him only six months but uh
yeah he wouldn't let me talk to anybody
or like hang out with any boys or
anything you know and even when I went
to work he would think I would lie to
him if I went somewhere else he's a
little bit like secondhand and not in a
way huh you're very very protective but
I don't talk to like that anymore
the last time I saw him I had a new
picture in my face and I shot I was
shooting up in the hospital and he was
sleeping next to me I didn't know he saw
me and then in the morning like he told
the nurses that he's dead he saw me
shoot up a nice broad night dirt they
were like looking at around my room in
the morning when I woke up to look for
my [ __ ] and they found my drugs and
stuff and I got my
[ __ ] I don't want to see him again and
he loved him but um where was I
right now right now is I take bars here
in there but it's mostly fed it no needs
to be Aaron and Krystal and we eat it
yeah everything no it's better not yeah
because Harry doesn't do [ __ ] to us you
know ain't no fair no zippy [ __ ] to me
you know I have to find ate there's
different types of federal no like their
shitty ones and there's a card fentanyl
now that they're selling on the streets
um and then there's this liquidy one
that's really good and there's blue if I
don't know there's pink I don't know you
know I am I turn I I didn't choose to I
didn't ever want it to like trade lip
stuff to make money but I am the way I
do it it's ice I've been helping people
get stuff you know and from there I get
it you know I get money to get my own
[ __ ] I get it for cheap but that's
because
I'm a girl and every every dealer that I
had liked has always tried to do [ __ ]
with me and now it's you know you gotta
do is share to survive you know it's
horrible you know what I never wanted to
like I don't like it and it's a horrible
like I'm so against people like you from
what my mom you know I was been through
I [ __ ] hate guys that take advantage
of women you know and like if I see
someone be taking a better job like this
girl the other day yesterday
she almost got here you know by this guy
because he thought he took his light his
flashlight yeah but yeah they're just
you're in the streets people people dude
[ __ ] like you can't even sleep at night
because we put one its head right so
yeah I get money from helping people
helping people get their [ __ ] you know
and I flip it so yeah I've been pretty
much salad you know yeah if I have to do
she other [ __ ] like you gotta do what
you gotta do that door whatever it takes
you know I never plan to sleep with
dealer I was sleeping with but I had to
I guess not I ended up liking him at the
end of my I didn't if they try you you
can't say no because then they get mad
and then they'll stop hooking you up you
know and I get a good deal so that's how
I usually we don't sleep I was sleeping
he left with this Mexican family for a
little bit it's
I slept in a tent here I slept in the
streets before yesterday I slept at
there's this guy who knows the dealer
and I really liked him and he had his
friend who they go and they boost I
boost - you know from the stores but
since my face sometimes when you look
too bad they know we think you can they
can tell you know you gotta look to look
at you but I used to make like one
hundred and eighty dollars just boost
them you know I boost sometimes though
still and I go to places where it's a
rich rich neighborhood because they
don't have securities and stores there
and I just got a turnout like 60 seconds
in it now you know because that's how
you got before they see your face in it
they're like oh can i yeah so I do that
but yeah I flip it I flipped the money
in like the whole day I spend going on
the bus like trading and today now
giving people [ __ ] you know my drug I
think I do like a gram and a half to be
honest I'm gonna tell you I shall
fair enough for like
120 110 a gram which is really pretty
good work and I get it for 70 so I guess
it will cost me like 78 for me like 124
and a half yeah if I didn't have to hook
up yeah it would be yeah I do yeah
his name is Carla your years at San
Diego he's two years old it's that but I
always wanted to be with him like I
promised to be to be there for him like
you know I was like before he turns it
to I'm gonna be there because then
they're gonna start remembering stuff
but up I didn't know it was a drug
addict I didn't even know about the ante
program I've been sober before until um
I got pregnant and I couldn't stop I
couldn't stop doing drugs and I was
already four months pregnant
and I was doing doing drugs so my
parents they lie to me they said hey
come visit us and Anisha cuz that's
where they were living man and you know
come visit us in Indonesia yes I was
pregnant I was like okay I'll come visit
you guys hey then I was living with this
dude dealer like 80
neither dude who like 12 girls coming in
now he's a man doing here in the only
that's crystal but he only has it so you
can [ __ ] all these [ __ ] like 20 year
old girls who's like you know that could
be their [ __ ] Grammy could be their
gram but yeah I went I went there and
they're like yeah your baby that he told
us even been hearin you know and you're
[ __ ] pregnant we're not gonna let you
not do any damage to the baby so you're
gonna [ __ ] stay here until like you
almost ready to have a baby you know so
I said Indonesia for a little bit and
when I was Adin you know eight months
and a half I went back to San Diego to
have my baby and I was really scared
that they were taking away so so I asked
the doctor he's like you know if you get
a lot of tests negative then they might
let you keep him so that I made sure
that the last three tests they were
negative me know I didn't know anything
until he was till he was four months I
got back into it you know maybe that uh
yeah I started again and then I asked my
mom I OD you know first time I with the
aggressive ear but I only like six times
after that
no on hearing like four times to
non-federal the first time I try federal
I shot it cuz I see already shoot and
they had to use tune organs on me I was
with my boyfriend by then I would did it
wake up the first one
and when I woke up I was like what the
[ __ ] cuz like Nike and makes you sober
right and I didn't realize like how bad
it was you know you're so [ __ ] like
not here yeah nice what like how bad is
the life that you're living you know
you're like look how the [ __ ] we're
living in it after I not gonna use like
no you gotta stay awake so I don't die
and then he what they do you know and
like I had to keep him awake like the
whole [ __ ] night so he doesn't die
you know after I'm sober they're like
just got hit by narcan so it was a bad
experience but yeah the first time I got
scared
um I already have my baby they took him
away
when I told uh I told my V daddy because
at some point we were went back to live
with him again I I wanted us to be a
family you know like for my mozi for my
son to have a dad in his life you know I
wanted him to I want the best for my son
I never I wanted to do drugs with him
you know even I was breastfeeding at
some point I moved to Florida with my
friend and I started doing crack and
herring in my my baby he didn't want to
do
you didn't want to do the bottle so I
had to breastfeed it while I was doing
this and like I have even left him in
the room you know and I took stolen my
friend's car to go and get like
Pinecrest and he's like he's like six
months old you know I gave it him bars
because I was too sick to take care of
him you know and I needed to sleep I was
just really [ __ ] up dude like he do
that to baby you know yeah but it
wouldn't he was ten months it's all his
dad and his dad called the cops and I
went to jail I told him that I was still
using and I needed help I couldn't stop
yeah he got mad at me he call the cops
but time I get out of jail I had a
restraining order and I was homeless
that's the first time I did anything
and they took my baby you know awake in
thanking me you couldn't get close I'm
gonna train you order so yeah my having
live of my baby ever since but a boy
always think I'm gonna get clean you
know and the time was fine you can have
time no boat all day you spend it trying
to get money to survive to eat if I
can't where you're gonna shower you know
that the whole day you spend it driving
buses to make money was he even survived
you know so you don't have time to ever
do these things but yeah I was supposed
to be there my son just turned 2 in
September 15 and yeah I didn't make it
for his birthday I started with this
Peruvian guy who let me stay in his
trailer but he say he probably like I
asked him first I didn't even do
anything you know if I'm going to stay
here because I don't want to have to do
something that I want to you know like
why you want to help me you know my girl
the streets feel insane you do drugs
it's weird when he said no but later no
he's like I'll help you out if you need
help you know like you just need to help
me out and yeah I don't stay with him
anymore because even one night and she
has one bed
I caught him like putting his hands
under the cover
you can't even [ __ ] sleep everybody's
[ __ ] up so I'm planning opening up a
tent here now because I don't really
have a place to sleep every night it's
different for me huh
before my ex-boyfriend what used to be
the car biz dad I have this guy I took
I'm just seeing it so like I'm just hard
to see last night you know and like we
slept at his friend's house when he went
boost and I don't I said he was gonna
come back you never came back
and I owe my methadone you know which is
more fun because it's another drug and
now I'm gonna get you know but I want to
get off this [ __ ] I'm I really am done
like I'm so tired of living this way but
I [ __ ] up like my family gave me so
many chances they don't trust me anymore
and I don't blame them and you don't
want me around and I understand but you
only have myself no I don't have anybody
I can't trust anybody like the guy is he
once extra beer here
I mean I don't know I don't have any
women friends only one make up but yeah
and I'm I do this I I have to do [ __ ]
every day different should every day to
survive like today
bleep that but maybe the Birdman guys
house I sleep in his closet now because
he has another friend live it man plug
that it's like this babies but it's
something
this means I have money I'm gonna buy it
finish put it over there yeah yeah I
think I'm gonna have to like sometimes
have to sleep if you have to it's
disgusting
like I'm really about that before I used
to protect my friends like I used to be
really like against uh you know
especially the way I was raised
Olivia and like people you uh you have
to be like come from a good family come
from a good last name you know in a good
school that's how they see you know
because everybody knows each other and
it's like your morals but I had good
morals and know it's like a [ __ ]
hurts me feel like not know you know you
know your this [ __ ] that you had to do
to be okay okay
doing [ __ ] that you have to do yeah like
right now my says once pick up my dealer
like he didn't even gave me I was coming
to reify [ __ ] eat with this food I
eat with the money at me and he stole
from me like two grandchildren when I'll
[ __ ] leave me you know cuz he eyeball
that [ __ ] and I'm the one that this is
money so don't [ __ ] after like starting
it I don't know how I have to wait but
I'm probably gonna have to go Bush today
[ __ ] somewhere to be honest - I'm just
your body but I want to get off the ship
I'm going to I want to tired of it but I
just don't get it dance it smartly you
see I want to it we mean it goodbye Nam
once you're sick it's different then
you're just like like this like I'm
gonna do whatever it takes to stop
feeling this way I can't even feel this
way because it's really horrible
sweet sick but you really want to like
my mom has tried nice to try to get me
sober and got a hotel room you know by
the third day Hey I would like to steal
their money where's this [ __ ] leave
her you know they just move they just
move they rented the house from
Indonesia they didn't stay there for
like four years and we just moved to
Sunnydale because the plan was like last
year for them to move here I was
supposed to live with them and you know
to have the kids together my little
brother who's three four and when you
know babies together you know was three
and nice to live together in San Diego
so we could be close to my baby and I
was supposed to have custody too
I mean this is my baby and is that Toby
I'd like the first ones after I'd up he
would wake up in the baby
that should push with you I don't think
other people are gonna have a kid I
don't like talking about I don't like
feeling I have any feelings for anybody
because I can't [ __ ] take my
so what guys what guys try to date me I
can take care of me like I'll be there
for you know that I can you know you
probably see like that guy last night
and where the [ __ ] is he say you know I
gave him what he wanted was just [ __ ]
sex you know I know where the [ __ ] is he
so I don't know I don't know anybody get
close to me like I really have face to
it guys like I don't talk to anybody
guys try talking to you when your
industry just walk into here what's up
shawty whatever you know say [ __ ] man
Thank You India if anything I have
scissors or a knife or something with me
you know good I already know better you
know but yeah you just have to everyday
you never know where you're gonna be
what's gonna happen to you why you're
gonna have to do you know but one day I
always say the next day I'm gonna get
clean you know I'm gonna stop honestly I
don't even know why I should better know
because I won't methadone it blocks the
fentanyl so I don't know why I do it you
know so now I did I get a crack today
you know I don't crack in [ __ ] beer
or something pretty good say I guess
there's not one drug at it I wouldn't
stop I just want to be normal I want to
be part of my kid's life I don't want to
be rich or Nothing man I just want a
house and be able to support my baby and
just be a good mom I have my how many
people I love close to me you know like
even when you're with people and you go
to work it boosts us stuff you always
feel like your own yeah because
everybody's selfish you this drug turns
you selfish like you become a person you
because someone you would you would
before a judge you know yeah I need the
person that I am like I don't like it I
hate people treat me the way they treat
me I can't do anything about it you know
oh you know people is seen in the
streets I used to be a person like a
little key person you know like look
good not happily abscissa [ __ ] like that
man I was dying one side to stay in
hospital fit some words because I heard
your card ideas yeah
just thinking my face like I used to
look normal but now I'm like how dare
they treat me like that you know -
because I look different now you don't
know that I used to be a decent person
you know
you know bro thank you